Guten Abend. Mein Name ist Seine Pilay-Philik. Ich bin hier die Dienstabende Erzim.
Umstelle ich Ihnen ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer kranken Geschichte.
Aber so erst möchte ich wissen, wie Sie heißen.
Ich heiße Sylvia Hansen.
Könnten Sie Ihre Vor- und Nachnamen buchstabieren?
Ja, der Vorname Sylvia, S-I-L-V-I-A.
Und der Familienname ist Hansen, H-A-N, S-E-N.
Frau Hansen, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 63 Jahre alt.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Am 1. Mai 62.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,68 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie so seit?
Ich wiege so 74 kg und immer hin und her.
Ich habe jetzt seit Tagen solche unglaublichen Kopfschmerzen.
Das pocht die ganze Zeit.
Was jetzt so ein bisschen unheimlich war,
heute Nachmittag fing das mit einmal an,
dass ich so komisches Flimmern vor den Augen hatte,
dass ich nicht mehr richtig gucken konnte.
Ich habe jetzt noch ein paar Tage,
dass ich noch etwas zu arbeiten, aber es ging überhaupt nicht.
Ich konnte überhaupt nicht mehr richtig sehen.
Da habe ich schon ein bisschen Panik bekommen.
Dann habe ich gedacht, ich komme jetzt doch mal hierher.
Was mir auch aufgefallen ist, ich könnte also ununter Wochen trinken.
Aber wie gesagt, diese Kopfschmerzen,
die habe ich jetzt schon seit Tagen.
Und es hört sich sehr gut.
Ich habe mich schon seitdem aufgefahren.
Die habe ich jetzt schon seit Tagen.
Und es hört überhaupt nicht auf.
Also auf beiden Seiten pocht das hier so in den Schläfen.
Es macht mich ganz fertig.
Ungefähr seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Ja, ich sage das seit drei Tagen.
Seit drei Tagen.
Heute ist ein bisschen schlimmer geworden, oder?
Ja, also heute finde ich es halt,
es ist deshalb so nervig,
weil ich mich überhaupt nicht mehr konzentrieren kann.
Weil ich solche Kopfschmerzen habe.
Und am Morgen geht es immer noch.
Da ist es nicht ganz so schlimm.
Aber im Laufe des Tages wird es dann immer schlimmer.
Aber eben diese komischen Sehstörungen,
dass sich mit einmal diese Sehstörung hatte,
das hat mich so ein bisschen erschreckt.
Und deswegen bin ich eben schnell zu ihm gekommen.
Sind Sie empfindlich von der Geräusche auch?
Nein, das eigentlich nicht.
Würde ich nicht sagen.
Wenn man Kopfschmerzen hat,
wenn da jetzt laut jemand Musik machen würde,
oder hemmern würde, würde ich wahrscheinlich schon sagen,
oh, kannst du nicht aufhören.
Aber so normale Geräusche kann ich mit umgehen.
Okay.
Und ich habe auch schon versucht, Ibuprofen zu nehmen.
Aber das hat eigentlich gar nichts geholfen.
Die sind am ersten Abend.
Und dann habe ich es am nächsten Tag noch einmal probiert,
damit ich ein bisschen schlagen kann.
Aber es ging überhaupt nicht.
Wie viel Minigram war denn Ibuprofen?
Oh, ich weiß gar nicht mehr.
Ich glaube, ich weiß nicht.
Sind das 400er, die ich zu Hause habe?
Ich weiß es gar nicht genau.
Das hat ja nicht geholfen, oder?
Nee.
Sind Ihre Schmerzen beidseitig?
Ja.
Wo sind die genau?
Ja, ich sagte ja, in der Schläfe, überwiegend.
Hier in der Schläfe.
Schranken die Schmerzen irgendwo hin?
Nein, es ist eigentlich ziemlich da beschränkt.
Gibt es etwas, das Ihre Schmerzen verschlimmert
oder verlimmert?
Ja, wenn ich Nacht so ein bisschen Ruhe hatte,
morgens geht es immer noch.
Aber so Stress, was ich, wenn ich bei der Arbeit
jetzt noch telefonieren muss, oder am Bildschirm was gucken,
dann wird es im Laufe des Tages immer schlimmer.
Hat Ihnen Schlafen geholfen?
Ja, ich habe zwar schlecht geschlafen,
aber es war morgens fast ein klein wenig besser als am Abend.
Können Sie Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind eher dumfe, stehende Autosierer?
Stechen nicht, stechen nicht.
Es ist so ein klopfende, drückende Klopfende Schmerzen.
Wie können Sie Ihre Schmerzen beweiten auf einer Schmerzgala?
Wobei eines ist sehr leichte Schmerzen
und es ist sehr stark Schmerzen.
Was meinen Sie?
Die stärkste Version wie jetzt am Abend,
würde ich sagen ist so bei acht.
Und morgens ist es vielleicht so bei sechs.
Hatten Sie schon mal eine Schmerzen?
Ja, jeder hat mal Kopfschmerzen.
Und ja, also im Zusammenhang,
doch ich habe das schon mal früher gehabt,
aber nicht so stark und nicht so andauernd.
Sind diese Schmerzen immer da oder gehen sie wieder weg?
Dieses Mal sind sie eben gar nicht weggegangen.
Das ist ja etwas, was mich so beunruhigt,
dass ich das seit drei Tagen habe.
Haben Sie viel Bart, Stärfluss oder Nachtschweiß?
Ich habe mich jetzt nicht gemessen auf die Idee,
bin ich gar nicht gekommen, aber Nachtschweiß habe ich nicht.
Sind Ihnen schwindelig?
Ist Ihnen schwindelig.
Nein, ich schwindelig.
Nein, ich schwindelig ist mir nicht.
Ich kann nur nicht gut gucken.
Ist Ihnen Öbel oder haben Sie schon mal ein Brochen?
Gott sei Dank nicht.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Normalerweise ist der gut,
jetzt heute natürlich nicht so sehr.
Haben Sie sich das nicht so stark ab oder so genommen?
Mein Gewicht ist eigentlich ziemlich stabil.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Normalerweise schlafe ich relativ gut.
Wenn ich viel Stress habe, kann ich auch mal ein schlafen.
Aber jetzt, bei den Nächten habe ich nicht gut geschlafen.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Wasser lassen oder Schulgang?
Nein.
Besuchen Sie Ihre Frauenarztin regelmäßig?
Ja, ich regelmäßig zu der Krebsversorgung.
Ich glaube, wir sind sie in sechs Jahren.
Ja, da bin ich schon durch.
Gott sei Dank.
Frau Hansen, leiden Sie an irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen?
Das meinen Sie damit?
Blutzuckerkrankheit oder Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe seit fünf Jahren diese Zuckerkrankheit.
Ich nehme mit Formin regelmäßig ein.
Damit ist das eigentlich ganz gut eingestellt.
Dann hat man ein bisschen davor,
hat man festgestellt, dass ich ein bisschen hohen Druck habe.
Das ist jetzt seit acht Jahren.
Nehmen Sie dagegen ein Medikament ein?
Ja, ich nehme Ramipril regelmäßig, morgens.
Wie viel Milligramm?
Das sind fünf Milligramm, glaube ich.
Einmal morgens, nehmendlich?
Ja, naja.
Wie ist die Dosierung von Medikament?
Das ist für die Siegtehne 850er, da nehme ich eine morgens und eine Abend.
Aber jetzt schon eine ganze Weile und das scheint irgendwie gut zu funktionieren.
Sind Ihre Blutdruck auch gut eingestellt?
Ja, die letzten Tage ist mir das aufgefallen.
Da habe ich eigentlich mal gemessen,
weil ich solche Kopfschmerzen hatte.
Da ist mir das aufgefallen,
dass der, als das anfing, war er bei 150 zu 80.
Heute Morgen war er nochmal dort, ich höre.
Da habe ich auch nochmal gemessen, da war er bei 180 zu 90.
180, 90.
Aber so hoch ist er normalerweise nie?
Ah, okay.
Seit zwei, drei Tagen.
Erhöft wieder.
Okay.
War das schon mal beim Hausarzt?
Nein, ich hatte so viel bei der Arbeit und konnte da nicht raus.
Deswegen bin ich gar nicht zum Hausarzt gegangen.
Aber als ich mit den Augen anfing, dass ich nicht mehr richtig gucken konnte,
habe ich gedacht, ich muss jetzt doch mal in die Klinik kommen.
Okay.
Sie haben gute Entscheidungen gemacht.
Sie haben eine gute Frau, Hansin.
Wo dann sich schon mal operiert?
Als Kind habe ich mal den Blinder rausbekommen.
Damals sind sie wie viele Jahre alt?
Oder war ich noch klein?
War ich gerade auf der Weiterführende in der Schule?
Ich muss zwölf oder so gewesen sein.
Das war jetzt keine große OP.
Aber weil das mit so einer Schlüsselloch OP gemacht wurde,
ist die geilen Blase rausgenommen.
Ist er entfällt, oder?
Die ist entfällt worden.
Das ist schon zehn Jahre her.
Hat er so einen geilen Stein?
Ja, ich hatte da Beschwerden.
Dann hat man mir das angeraten, die rauszumachen.
Und seitlich geht es besser.
Okay.
War das schon mal im Krankenhaus, oder hat den Särchen Unfall?
Bei dieser OP war ich natürlich im Krankenhaus.
Bei dieser Lapparoscopie war ich kurzfristig im Krankenhaus.
Unfall oder so was?
Ich habe es nicht.
Ausnahmeformin und Ramipril.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf Medikamente ein?
Nein, sonst.
Ich habe das Ibuprofen da, wenn es mal irgendwo wehtut.
Aber normal nehme ich keine Medikamente.
Sind Ihnen allergisch gegen etwas?
Oder haben Sie Unverträglichkeiten?
Ja, ich habe ja Geschwindigkeit.
Ich darf keine Zillen haben.
Wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Ich habe da mal einen heftigen Ausschlag bekommen.
Eine Gesichterhaltung.
Ein Ausschlag an den Armen.
Das war nicht so schön.
Frau Hansel,
jetzt möchte ich über Ihre Genussmitage-Wohnheiten etwas erfahren.
Sie haben nicht geraucht.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Wenn es etwas zu Feier gibt.
Wenn man mal eingeladen ist zum Essen.
Dann trinke ich auch mal ein Alkohol.
Aber mein Glas Wein.
Oder im Sommer mal eine Flasche Bier.
Oder wenn man mit einem Glas Sekt mal anstößt.
Aber eigentlich eher wenig.
Wie auch?
Was denken Sie?
Wie viele Festes gibt es schon zu feiern?
Wenn das vielleicht 4 Mal im Monat ist,
dann ist das schon viel.
4 Mal im Monat.
Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine Routinefrage, die ich Ihnen in der Videobeschreibung
über die Frage über die Frage nachdenken.
Ich habe keine Erfährung.
Frau Hansen,
als nächstes möchte ich über Ihre Familienkrankheiten
etwas fragen.
Leiden Ihre Eltern irgendwelche Erkrankungen
und leben Sie noch.
Meine Mutter, die lebt noch,
die hat eine Erkrankung.
Sie hat eine Erkrankung.
Meine Mutter, die lebt noch,
die hat Arthose in den Knien.
Das, was die meistens schwierig macht.
Mein Vater lebt schon lange nicht mehr.
Er ist nur 40 Jahre alt geworden.
Er hat eine Staublunge.
Er hat im Bergbau gearbeitet.
Er ist leider gar nicht mehr alt geworden.
Haben Sie Geschützter?
Ja, wir waren eine große Familie.
Ich hatte vier Geschwister.
Eine Schwester ist früh gestorben.
Die hatte mit Anfang 60 ein Herzinfarkt.
Aber die anderen sind so viel.
Ich weiß, wir haben nicht so engen Kontakt.
Wie viele Geschwister haben Sie?
Es waren viele.
Es waren viele Geschwister.
Wir waren insgesamt fünf.
Eine Schwester ist verstorben.
Was machen Sie vom Beruf, den ich verhauchen soll?
Ich bin Buchhalterin.
Wir haben eine Tischlerei.
Mein Mann ist der Chef.
Ich arbeite in der eigenen Firma.
Das ist Stress.
Ich habe eine kleine Familie.
Ich habe viel zu tun.
Ich mache das sehr gerne.
Sind Sie feiereratet?
Wir sind feiereratet.
Aber sind Sie Kinder?
Ja, zwei erwachsene Töchter.
Sie sind aus dem Haus.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, sie sind gesund.
Ich habe alle meine Fragen gestellt.
Haben Sie Fragen?
Ich möchte Sie etwas hinzufügen.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Was kann man gegen Kopfschmerzen machen?
Woher kommt das?
Es könnte eine Migräne sein.
Aber ich kann Ihnen die Diagnose später sagen.
Das ist eine Verdacht.
Ich muss die Körperung untersuchen.
Ich muss ein paar Labor untersuchen.
Ich muss gegen einen Bildgebäude verfahren.
Ich muss gegen ein Bildgebäude verfahren.
Das kann man für Bildgegendes machen.
Zum Beispiel einen MRT.
Das können wir kann lassen.
Was tut das weh?
Nein, es ist eine Schmerzfrei-Verfahren.
Ja, ein Schmerzfreies-Verfahren.
Okay, ja.
Ja, gut, aber das erklären Sie mir noch mal später, was ich da genau gemacht habe.
Okay, gut.
Ja, vielen Dank.
Ja, ne.
Jetzt bitte ich Sie einen Pilaz im Markt, Sie müssen nehmen.
Dann rufe ich Sie wieder auf.
Okay, gut.
Danke.
Die Formulierung heißt, ich bitte Sie im Wartezimmerplatz zu nehmen,
nicht einen Platz, sondern im Wartezimmerplatz zu nehmen.
Mhm.
Okay.
Gut, wer hat noch Fragen?
Hat noch jemand Fragen?
Haben Sie auch Nackenschmerzen?
Nee, Nackenschmerzen habe ich nicht.
Sonst war nichts Anfragen.
Zackig.
Zügig, zügig.
Ja, sehr gut.
Wunderbar.
Ich habe einen guten Tag Frau Oberarztin, ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen,
die ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Haben Sie seid dafür?
Ja, natürlich.
Es handelt sich um Frau Sylvia Hansen.
Sie ist 63 Jahre alt, 1,68 m groß und 74 kg schwer.
Sie ist seit 3 Tagen vorwegend,
die drückende Klopfen, die dauerhaft beidseitige Kopfschmerzen
ohne Ausstrahlung besonders...
Ach, begreift.
Kopfschmerzen.
Agi?
Ja.
Ohne Ausstrahlung besonders im Temporalregion.
Mhm.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt bis 6 bis 8 vom 10 auf einer Schmerzkala.
Die Schmerzen sind begleitet von seit heute Nachmittag eine Sehstörung
wegen Schmerzen, eine Konzentrationsschweche, auch Geräuschempfindlichkeit.
Die Schmerzen sind sich in der Laufezeit schlimmer geworden
oder verstechtert.
Und dagegen haben die Patienten 2-mal über Profil 400 mg eingenommen,
aber ohne deutliche Wirkung.
Mhm.
Langseitige...
Langseitige am Computer zu arbeiten
und Stress seien sich mal verschlechtert
und beim Schlafen seien die Schmerzen lindert.
Mhm.
Die früher ähnliche Beschwerden wurden vernei, verja, bejacht.
Aber war nicht so...
nicht so andauernd und nicht so schlimm.
Nicht so andauernd, genau, ja.
Mhm.
Nicht so schlimm wie heute Nachmittag.
Ähm...
Dann ähm...
Sie leide an arterielle Hypertonies seit 8 Jahren,
deswegen äh...
habe sie ihre Produktdruck gemessen
und war 150 äh...
80 äh...
bis 160 90.
Mhm.
Ein bisschen erhöht.
Äh...
Um der Begewägte, die war Anamnese,
äh... er gab eine Insomnie, äh...
in Vor-Einschlafsstörungen wegen äh...
diese Beschwerden und Stress.
Ähm...
Die Frage nach Schwindel, ähm...
Er brach es, äh...
und äh...
Er nahe es, er nahe es, äh...
Genokologische Anamnese seien auch unaufwählig.
Mhm.
fünf Jahre eine Diabetes-Mendritus Typ 2, die mit Formin 850 Milligramm einmal morgens und einmal
abends behandelt werden und Arterielechbatonis seit acht Jahren, die mit Ramipril fünf Milligramm
einmal morgens behandelt werden. Und mit zwölf Jahren ist eine Appendectomie erfolgt und
vor zehn Jahren eine laparoscopische Kolisistiktonie wegen Kolioliteasis erfolgt. Sie nehmen regelmäßig
mit Formin Ramipril und bei Bedarf überfroffern 400 Milligramm ein. Bei ihr sei eine Penicillinallergie
bekannt, die genialisierten Exanten und Erritem äußert, die Nikotinkonsum und Drogenkonsum
wurden verneint, aber sie trinken viermal pro Monat ungefähr ein Glas Sekt oder ein
Fleisch Bier oder ein Glas Wein. Also sehr moderater Alkoholkonsum. Parties oder Feiern. In der Familienanamnese
es gibt eine Konatrose bei der Mutter und eine Penemokonnose beim Vater. Er sei daran gestorben mit 40
Jahre alt. Sie habe vier Geschwister und ein davon am Neukardinfarkt verstorben im Alta 80 Jahre.
Sie ist Buchhalterin in eigener Tüchzei. Sie habe Stress bei der Arbeit und sei verheiratet und
habe zwei gesunde Töchter. Sehr gut. Was ist denn jetzt Ihre Vermutung? Woher hat sie ihre Kopfschmerzen?
Die anomistischen Angaben durften auf eine Migreme hin. Aber als Differenzialdiagnostisch kommen
sie ein Hintumor oder die Pertensivatake in Betracht. Was könnte es noch sein? Angesichts der Vorerkrankung?
Sie haben Diabetes. Vielleicht erhöhte Blutzuckerwerte. Aber diese schwarze Verlosaufe.
Was machen Sie diagnostisch mit der Patientin?
Ich muss als Patientin die Körperlöhung untersuchen.
Worauf achten Sie bei der Körperlöhung?
Ich muss besonders eine Nörologie und eine Ersuchung durchführen.
Ich achte auch die Populienreflexes. Muskelkräfte.
Was noch?
Die Taupheitsgefühl. Parästhesie kann ich auch kontrollieren.
Die perfärische Reflexe kann ich auch kontrollieren.
Was machen Sie noch außerdem?
Bei der Pallpassion kann ich auch den Kopf palpieren. Besonders die Pulse.
Die Artälielle Temporalisten kann ich palpieren.
Dann kann ich die Nackentstehfigkeit kontrollieren.
Sehr gut.
Was bestimmen Sie noch?
Dann kann ich eine Laboruntersuchung durchführen.
Was lassen Sie da bestimmen?
Bei der Labor machte ich darauf, ob die Patientin vielleicht eine Anämie hat.
Anämie kann die Kopfzimmers verursachen.
Zusätzlich verritzt die Eisen, die Vitamin B, die Würfe.
Dann kann ich auch die Nebelwerte kontrollieren.
Denken Sie noch mal an die Vorerkrankung?
Die Blutzucker.
Die Blutzucker-Messung.
Was ist noch elementar im Rahmen der körperlichen Untersuchung,
bevor Sie Labor bestimmen?
Auch im Hinblick auf die Vorerkrankung, auf die Angaben der Patientin?
Die Produktdruckmessung.
Alle Vitamin-Parameter muss ich auch messen.
Was könnte man als weiterführende Untersuchung
technischer Art noch durchführen?
Ich kann eine Schädel-MRT antworten.
Mit welcher Fragestellung?
Um Hintenmörern auszuschließen.
Sie vermuten, dass das eine Migräne ist.
Was spricht für die Migräne?
Die Schmerzcharakter von Sephalgie,
besonders hochende Klopfen,
wenn die durchkante Schmerzen,
die im Rahmen der Temporalregion sind.
Aber?
Es ist unbeigseitig.
Ist das typisch für Migräne?
Nein.
Sie haben ein paar Sachen gefragt.
Bei der Patientin, die Sie alle verneint.
Was ist das für die Migräne?
Siehstürungen, Geräusche.
Konzentrationsfläche.
Was fehlt für die Migräne?
Aura und Emesis.
Das fehlt.
Sie sind sehr traurig.
Sie berichtet die Patientin nicht von Aura.
Sie befragen die Patientin weiter.
Untersuchen Sie sie.
Halten Sie mich auf den Laufen.
Was am Ende rausgekommen ist.
Ich muss Ihnen ein Kompliment machen.
Sie haben sich richtig doll verbessert.
Sie haben eine schöne Anfängerung.
Sie haben eine schöne Anamnese gemacht.
Sie haben ein paar sprachliche Kleinigkeiten.
Sie haben auch eine sehr komplette und sprachliche Präsentation gemacht.
Das ist richtig gut gelaufen.
Das ist ein bisschen korrigiert.
Das ist eine sprachliche Winzigkeit.
Sie haben gesagt,
zu der Schmerzskala.
Wo ist die Schmerzen auf einer Skala?
Es gibt ein paar Winzigkeiten.
Wo ist der Schmerz auf einer Skala?
Wo ordnen Sie die Schmerzen?
seguir.
Das war eine Winzigkeit.
Das ist mir aufgefallen.
Das war komischerweise.
Die Schwester.
60 am Herzinfarkt gestorben. Ja, ich habe mich zu ihr schreiben 60, aber warum habe ich nicht den Fakt?
Ja, man stirbt auch nicht mit 60. Also gut, okay. Und genauso auch Zahlenproblemen.
Heute Morgen hat sie angegeben, hat sie 180 zu 90 gehabt, nicht 160 zu 90.
Das ist ja schon auch deutlich hoch. Und ja, insofern, das wären auch die hier angegebenen Hauptdiagnosen,
dass man sagt entweder entgleister Diabetes oder hypertensive Krise.
Und für die Migräne spricht tatsächlich diese Sehstürung, aber die Migräne dauert im seltensten Schellen so lange.
Und sie ist eigentlich klassischerweise auch einseitig. Und sie ist zudem auch, es hat ja jemand auch gefragt,
haben sie Sensibilitätsstörungen in den Händen. Klassischerweise hat die Migräne ja auch auf der Gegenseite die neurologischen Ausfälle.
Das ist eine der wenigen Krankheiten, über die ich selber Erfahrungen habe.
Ich habe mir in Zeit lang in meinem Leben wüste Migräneattacken gehabt, deswegen kann ich beschreiben, wie die Situation ist.
Und das klassische an der Migräne sind eben diese bohrenden Schmerzen.
Einseitig und auf der Gegenseite die Symptomatik, die zum Teil wirklich heftig sein kann.
Und insofern und natürlich die Übelkeiten mit dem Unstillbaren Erbrechen, das sind so Migräne-Erfahrungen.
Und das ist eigentlich alles nicht gegeben. Insofern sind die beiden anderen Diagnosen schon irgendwo wahrscheinlicher.
Es muss ja nicht gleich der Hirntumor sein. Hoffen wir mal, dass sie tatsächlich nur einen entgleisten Diabetes hat.
Vielleicht auch in Kombination mit einer Hochdruckphase durch Stressbeding kann alles sein.
Gut, wenn sie jetzt tatsächlich eine hypertensive Krise hat, was geben Sie der Patientin? Was machen Sie mit mir?
Ich kann jetzt nicht erinnern.
Ja, Sie müssen ja die Blutdruck senken.
Ja, ich muss die Blutdruck senken mit antiprtensive.
Ja, genau. Aber eben nicht haurop, sondern langsam.
Und wenn es tatsächlich eine Hyperglyke-Mis, was machen Sie dann?
Hyperglyke-Mis oder?
Hyperglyke-Mis, wenn sie einen hohen Blutzucker hat.
Ja, ich kann eine Infusion verabreichen und unter Sucherkontrolle.
Das wollte ich gerade sagen. Das wäre nur in dem Fall, dass der Blutzucker wirklich extrem hoch ist.
Da müsste man da entsprechend einsteigen und wirklicherweise kurzfristig die Medikation da umstellen für diesen Altersdiabetes.
Gut, ja.
Ja, also hat mir dort nicht gut gefallen.
Ich denke mal, Sie können doch jetzt ziemlich entspannt Ihrer Prüfung entgegensehen.
Wie gesagt, irgendwann habe ich zwischendrin mal einen Grammatikfehler korrigiert, aber das war minimal.
Also hat sich wirklich, finde ich, sehr, sehr verbessert.
Und ja, schauen Sie, dass es am Anfang, bei Ihrer Prüfung, dass es richtig gut läuft.
Ja, am vierten Juni. Hoffentlich kann ich es sehen.
Ja, ich wünsche Ihnen alles Gute und für heute Abend sind wir schon durch.
Sie waren schnell, sie waren auch schnell in der Zeit.
Und haben das sehr straight gemacht, hat mir sehr gut gefallen.
Gut, wir sehen uns, wenn gewünscht.